yeah and I just wanted to apologize to
kalila because um you know you go
through this relationship and you
realize I'm a bad boyfriend and I'm very
difficult with I am very difficult to
live with and I'm a disaster I don't
know how anyone deals with me I'm moody
I'm I'm I'm [ __ ] quick I want I want
to call all of your ex-girlfriends and
give him like a like a civilian award or
so of some sort yeah I just say hey look
like thank you for dealing with him
before me
why because I'm sure at some point to
some degree they primed you to be a
better version than you know you were
when they first met you so little by
little each woman that has been with you
has made you a little bit better and I
think that's finally by the time I
received you you were a little bit more
tolerable I understand that but you know
what I'm pure gold poor spirit and those
are two things that are fights a fact
okay and I have character defects but
don't you ever forget about what I am
Who I am is slap slap you know about son
Campbell yep okay so um so I want to
tell you what happened to me last week
mm-hmm and I don't I don't know you know
we talk about show business I know I
don't really like it you know um look I
just want to think that I really believe
this about myself that I literally
believe that I have no talent because
people go oh you were funny you don't
know what's going on in the inside mmm
when I'm doing things you know like when
I'm performing like they know you're
terrible you know I don't have a good
self-esteem right so this year I was
just like you know my agents like you
know there's not a lot of pilots you
know so I go oh I want to go on see you
will you there's five so you got to go
out for at least a five yeah
so literally every single audition they
got get gave me I just said I'm not
doing it well you went to to die did oh
wait not Network though no no they were
um I did a couple of movies or something
yeah yeah so I just said I'm not doing
policies and I'm because you know I'm
doing a little bit of love a couple
episodes and then I got Diplo so I'm
like I'm fine and then last week I'm
driving down the street and everyone
calls and they go congratulations like
Oh what you got a pilot
I don't know Edition right so go what is
it are you sure this is a trick just
Preki
no because you know you know when people
do it right I don't know I'll just check
it out when you [ __ ] do it
mmm this is what you see you show up
there's about a hundred people in the
lobby they're all reading for the same
part you go in they go go you do it
thank you
and then you leave and you never hear
from them again
that's all every audition go through
that again
because then once you get through that
first one then you get a callback
we're producers watch you and they thank
you if you get through that you have to
do three or four other [ __ ] things
it's a nightmare
and I don't have the I don't have the
spirit to do it but you have a pure
spirit we've been practicing
manifestation yeah you know we instead
of going to these auditions
we know that every day we're like we
want a new house yeah we want something
you just fall in our lap we want we want
your place so that we can get a bigger
Tiger belly studio yeah so that we could
have bigger guests and it's for you
people doing this for you I mean for
Bobby's a win for all of us so but if
you check it out so then I show up so I
guess I get it and I read it and I go
you know I can't tell you who was in
everybody okay people are in it and then
arm but today they go well yesterday I
was in Houston flying in and they go you
have to come
and you have to do a table read because
they don't know if I can even do it
right so now they're like come in you
got the part we offered it to you but
you have to read it in front of everyone
and then you know good we're gonna we
might go nah mm-hmm my god right but I
was like my flight was delayed so I
missed it I'm gonna Houston sorry but
that today they go you got to do it
again today you had to come early so the
whole cast like six people showed up
with all the producers and it was my
turn to talk and I swear to god this is
what came out so let's just say hey Bill
I my name is I'm not gonna tell you the
character because I want to mention what
hey Joseph the grocery store is the
other way aye-aye-aye
that's how it came out I'll be okay no
that's how it came out and when I was
talking you can see everyone do my proof
of peripheral side I fine he's done he's
eating it and this is disaster and
there's also four kids in the show and
they're all like you know mean kids who
sit their lives perfectly or look at me
like yeah this guy's done who is this
guy who is this guy and so afterwards
done then we had to go to the bigger
room now in the big room you have Warner
Brothers president Oh God ABC president
all the executives and I literally did
it like I was speaking your language
baby yeah oh yeah yeah like it was
literally soft so that I took my script
and I showed you guys this right and I
wrote down little [ __ ] notes oh they
can't see this and then put right here I
put right here just read it right just
for those most actors put acting knows
yeah I don't know I don't I just read it
though I yell at my own self right watch
what I put here slow three your notes
basically jab because those are things
that I understand cuz they're big bold
letters right so what the [ __ ] up man
it's as slow as I go the I slow it down
because what happens to me
I get so nervous I read a fast and then
I my mind is ahead of what I'm saying
and there's it's a crank train crash all
the words and then comes up my that's a
why that comes out that way
damn right the same way are you really
I get nervous you get nervous right for
our watches you got speed to the line
why I don't know you're saying it so
fast
right you think you're doing Asian actor
lose my coach so then I so then I did
the notes and I literally I did a prayer
to God because this could have been but
the Lord Jesus because you know I've
talked about this my finger touching my
finger right I've talked about that
right I did that right and he touched it
and it went perfectly
Bravo in that after don't clap don't
[ __ ] Patrignano Patra normal don't
have to know me me okay that's what
you're doing right now
oh right I'm not no I'm not I didn't say
it out of for applause I said it because
I survived it sorry Kang okay okay um
now I have to do it and I'm shooting it
next week that's huge it'll be fine
[Music]